killing joe biden's agenda could soon
put a lot more americans out of work
the president and democrats have been
pushing to more than double
the minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
the nonpartisan congressional budget
office says the plan
would cost you ready 1.4 million jobs
and while democrats get ready to ram
through their almost 2 trillion dollar
stimulus plan
they want to pack it with even more
government giveaways the democrats are
proposing
sending families checks every month that
adds up to over
three thousand dollars per child for a
year
i wonder if i get those checks you know
you might be priced out
you don't i don't think so dana tell me
i'm paying for that what's going on here
this see this seems this seems like
really bad economics
so yes so the congressional budget
office right you either live by it or
you die by it when you are in the
opposition you tend to love the
congressional budget office when you are
in power like at the white house you
tend to
like blow off the congressional budget
office as for not being very accurate
um so you know consider that um i
was kind of surprised this morning on
america's newsroom we had bret baer on
and i
believed that in that vote-a-rama last
week when senators ernst and lucas were
able to
get a bipartisan agreement that said you
should not raise the minimum wage during
a pandemic
and it passed bipartisanly and then you
saw president biden say you know look i
don't think it's even going to make it
into the bill
well apparently jesse that is it's now
very much back on the table to include
this goes back to that segment when we
were talking about bernie sanders
um and why he's not that unhappy about
not being president because he is
able to have some influence the other
thing that's happening that is driving
me
up a wall amazon has been advertising
all throughout the inside the beltway
publications about how they
support a 15 an hour minimum wage and
i'm all for people making more money
but amazon has already gobbled up the
mom and pops of this country
and now they're trying to curry favor
with the democrats to try to say oh look
we actually have done such a great thing
and now the mom and pops that
wouldn't be able to necessarily survive
and let's just say in the middle of the
country somewhere
for on 15 an hour my last point on this
another thing i didn't realize until
karl rove told me today
in this bill in the proposal that they
have the minimum wage would increase
automatically as the median wage of the
country went up
so if this passes and it could pass very
well on a reconciliation vote that means
that
it will happen every year as there's a
median wage increase
and who's going to be the politician
that gets elected
on taking that away from people so
really evil just might be you
politicians
you might be the one you could do he
would have to be so
evil and mean i can see greg he's so
excited to talk about the minimum wage
hike
only only global warming statistics
excite greg more than this go ahead greg
well you know i i i realize that when
you use the kind of the left
right uh dichotomy thing you never
convince the other side
right right it's just it's never going
to happen so i've realized that with
something like what's going on right now
it's more of like the activist world
it's not because i love progressives
some of my best friends are progressives
i probably have more progressive friends
than than i have conservative friends
but i it's the activist it's the
activist world
where there is no cost for one's actions
there's always this someone else
outside your identity that foots the
bill it's some vague amorphous
rich white fat cat who's probably racist
so you know whatever so you'll have the
cost of amnesty which will lower
labor costs and reduce employment for
lower economic classes
and you know that hiking the minimum
wage will reduce the number of jobs
strictly by
economics which believe it or not is an
actual science
unlike identity politics which the
democrats believe
is a science so the people making these
decisions pretend
to care about the poor but they're just
high enough
up on that ladder that they can't
actually see the poor
juan you agree with that
no it's not a surprise but no i mean
you know first of all i think there's a
real debate to be had here
about the minimum wage and so i welcome
the debate
but i do think that in order to have an
honest debate you have to say
all that the cbo found not just one
number in terms of the 1.4 million jobs
lost
because the cbo also indicated that you
would give
raises to 17 million americans jesse
17 million americans and you would not
only
that you would pull 900 000 working
americans these are people go to work
eight hours every day
but as a result of this they would
escape poverty
and you add another 10 million onto that
who would get
increases in pace so you understand that
for lower income people this would be
wonderful this would be a break in other
words it's you know
the to to have the debate and i welcome
this because i think it's a real debate
to be had
no i think you get 12 people basically
get a raise and and by the way the raise
would take them to just about thirty
thousand
dollars a year this is nothing grand
okay so 12 people get a raise
one person does lose a job so we have to
contend with that
so let's have the debate part of this
also has to do with kids you know
they're talking about a child cared
uh tax credit that's not really a tax
credit but what's
giving families money every year for
children
that's so important to me i just think
if you give a kid a chance
and we have terrible childhood hunger in
this country
there's a better chance for that child
to grow up to be a you know a
hard-working american who pays taxes and
takes care of life in his community or
her community so basically what you're
saying is if you're against the minimum
wage
you don't want you don't like children
getting fed
you hate families i mean we all want
this juan what you're stating is
something obvious
we all want this we just you know what
you're doing is actually hurting more
people
than it's helping that's the actual
argument it's not about like
who's starving who's not it's about the
minimum wage is designed as the first
rung on the ladder to get people in the
workplace and then
up if you make if you make that wage
higher you're going to eliminate those
numbers of jobs it's just
mathematics it's not about being you
know not
hating families or not wanting poor
people to eat
i'm so tired of that emotional argument
because
i didn't
what i said to you was i welcome the
real debate i just wanted to point out
how this is strongly going to pull
an incredible number of americans out of
poverty and i i said it would come as a
result
you know for every i think it's 12
americans who get a raise you'd lose one
one american would lose a job let's have
the debate but i didn't say what you
just said i don't put it in those
draconian terms
okay it's going it's going to pull
people out of poverty by putting more
people in poverty and it's a direct
reflection of the left's idea of
government
it's okay if we kill a million and half
jobs because we're passing a two
trillion dollar stimulus package where
we give you three thousand dollars to
your kid
we give you a check of fourteen hundred
dollars even though we promise to
uh thousand dollars and it goes back to
the keystone thing too like
it's fine if we kill all of these oil
and gas jobs the government's going to
implement policies that allow you to
work at a solar panel job even though
those jobs don't exist yet so it's a
reflection of the ideology that
more government is better which
ultimately as dana pointed out gives
them more power
because they implement these things that
make it harder to pull them back once
they're put in place
all right how was that for a debate
about the wage juan
pretty good